i'm sorry guys i'm sorry
my dog
i have like a power box thing
my dog
like was on it loki
um was pearly really gonna eat on the
stream mind your business this is my
channel i will in fact eat on the stream
i'm starving
you don't have to watch sir
it's like mind your
find your business
oh my god
let me go back
oh my god this [ __ ] is so good
okay
my dog she saw the food she was like
going crazy
we still eating
okay what are my rules and regulations
um
nothing attacking appearances
of anyone anyone
um
no trolls
anyone that makes a fake account
of anyone of me of donovan of anyone
that you're impersonating someone you're
not
you will get blocked that is not
cool um okay let me go back to the video
okay
um
okay the red pill is toxic
this one is going to be
you know by and by most of these guys
standards would probably be like oh
she's pretty cool she's pretty hot
i mean she's got a 23 year old boyfriend
right now i'm sure he probably qualifies
as most of those most of those dudes
so
so when we if you're gonna criticize
these guys and say they're angry
at least do them the service the
courtesy of saying well why why did they
get to that why did they come to that
it's not because i told them
you know you should really not like
women you should really protect yourself
oh you know
uh be mr you know be a cold-hearted son
of a [ __ ] like the rolo's telling them
all to do that no no i'm not in fact i
get in trouble for not telling them that
i show data sets i i'm the i'm the one
who is using the same data as the guys
she's interviewing or chris williamson
is interviewing or god knows who else is
interviewing right they're going to
interview rob
her dad right jordan peterson i use his
data i use
god sod's data i use rob henderson's
data i use
rolf's data i you guys know i use the i
use these data sets all the time
but they have no come back to any of
that you're just hurt
the reason why you're even bringing that
up is because you have some deep seated
angst and some horrible thing who hurt
you let's go let's do uh uh was it a
childhood regression therapy and see
where all i hate i'm sorry
[Music]
when people say who hurt you because it
shouldn't matter
is he right or is he wrong that's that's
what we're questioning
okay this comes from
no
no we won't we don't have to because i'm
not i'm not in any way hurt i am showing
you data sets i am trying to be as close
to
objective rational reasoning as i
possibly can but that's not the argument
that we're having that's not the debate
and all you want to do is hear stories
that confirm what you felt
you know yeah and and we would even see
with even with our channel we could do a
video about you know we do video to help
men you know
pick the right person also to avoid the
wrong person but all my friends in the
space will tell you you get ten extra
views
emphasize notice how he says we teach
guys how to pick the right person and
avoid the wrong person right
as if they're doing the selecting
as a you know it's funny because i i i
think i've heard these guys talk about
this as well because it constantly gets
uh repeated it's like oh women are the
gatekeepers of sex and men are the gay
keepers of commitment [ __ ] they are
oh yeah well we'll teach you how to
actually
i was surprised by how many men have
told me that they can sleep with a girl
that not get commitment from her i'm
like that seems like such a reverse
problem
i was not expecting that i can i can
show you right now again you want to
look at some statistics i can show you
right now that you know was it 30 of
guys below the age of 30 what i forget
what it is i'm gonna go look up that
data set real quick here while we're
listening to this but a few far fewer
men are having sex today but women are
still having the same amount of sex
imagine that we don't talk about that
data set we don't say well i want to
choose the right woman well okay well
what if the right woman is the one who
is uh
the outlier right what if she is the one
who is part of that uh you know that
cohort that is still having sex and
you're the guy that's not
is that about feeling bad no it's just
you happen to be in that cohort and she
doesn't happen to be in it
so all this [ __ ] about like oh we're
gonna teach you how to choose the right
woman yeah okay great
that's a noble aspiration don't get me
wrong and i hope you do i hope men can
at least in some way learn to vet women
but the thing is the simple fact is men
are not allowed to have standards we're
not not in a gynocentric social order he
knows this and in fact he wouldn't even
be employed he wouldn't have his manhood
courses if that weren't true
i think negative traits then you do
emphasizing the positive traits because
so many people just want to sit in the
negativity well yeah yeah he's
addressing none of the stuff that rolo
talked about with her on the podcast
none of it for thumbnails i know that if
you put something like how to have you
know put something negative on the
thumbnail yeah it's not like how to
become hotter it's like how to become
less ugly that's a bad example but that
one will make the ugly one will make
will get more views people are also
evolutionarily
predisposed to avoiding negativity right
so it's just anything negative is going
to stand out i think people remember
negative experiences more too
so
that makes sense yeah because and then
people don't realize and and i was
trying to explain i try to explain to
the guys in my audience the capitalistic
nature
behind some of the red pill content
and and and yeah
yeah yeah i'm curious what
why did i why did that flicker in your
mind i'm curious oh well when i when i
had the conversation with rolo and i was
like i have an instagram email
comparing me to someone who killed their
child yeah
okay there's lie number two so let's
stop it right there
and uh so that's uh i want to touch on
that really quickly here uh at michaela
because we need to this probably hasn't
been pretty me eating i was so hungry
you don't even know
you don't even when i see a lie i have
to call out that lie so
uh this is the thumbnail she's talking
about
am i in any way comparing her to casey
anthony in this
particular thumbnail
i'll i'll wait
anybody
bueller hello
no
in fact um this uh this image right here
we'll i'm gonna let her continue a
little bit further but her real problem
with this was not because
he said this is just
a dynamic and it makes me so mad because
the whole time
she's like
oh that wasn't nice i'm like how many
times did he say the same thing
he said the same thing to you
this is the dynamic i'm not saying she
actually wants to kill her kid like
so many times
i'll tell you this if all she had to go
on was just the thumbnail here she did
not know casey anthony was even brought
into the conversation here what she was
upset about was the image of her
and uh and our good friend uh andrew
tate
uh resurfacing on a thumbnail
uh right around the same time that she's
uh decided that she's gonna get with her
23 year old boy toy
and uh we'll we'll i'll explain to you
that here in just a moment but this is
the uh this is the thumbnail she's
referring to am i in any way making any
kind of comparison
to casey anthony here or
am i just simply showing a picture that
she probably would like to see go away
is that what's happening here because
that's that i think that's really
important
it's like that
i didn't like that that wasn't very nice
right and he was like yeah but it gets
he like full on said it gets more clicks
you know how youtube is and i was like
well
okay
but like maybe that's a little bit far
right like i get it he's like well yeah
but i know how to make thumbnails and
like people want to see people argue
online yeah and he was like full-on
full-on said i said this when i reacted
that earlier
no that's not what he said that was so
irritating
he makes up stories kind of makes up or
plays into stories or makes these
comparisons
to get more views because people all
right there's lie number three let's go
and let's go and have a look over at
this episode 131 of the michaela
peterson podcast last episode before
2022
i thought i'd stick this episode in as
the last to close off a very weird year
it's featuring rolo tomasi author of
many books including the rational mail i
invited role um
that's the only book series that i have
michaela
just in case you were wondering whether
or not she'd actually done her homework
or research
that right there should have been your
first clue to talk about his book before
finding out he'd done a somewhat nasty
in-depth video about what he thinks my
life is like which has about 160 000
views
okay
um that is actually lie number four
which we have to address before lie
number three
so
she what she's saying here what she's
trying to uh
back pedal on
and she's saying that well you know i
was gonna i was just sweetly innocently
gonna have him on my show to talk about
his book
uh the rational mail amongst other books
and i was gonna have him on but that was
unbeknownst to me before i realized that
he had done this horrible
horrible uh
thumbnail and and had done a nasty video
on me okay uh well no that's actually
not true because uh this was the
instagram
story reel whatever that she had
produced uh right around the end of
november of 2021 this was before i even
got the call from her i got it from
she she was i don't know if they still
are but she was supposed to go on with
myron and fresh i think she might even
be going on sometime this week or
sometime in february
um
but this was a screen cap of and thank
you for
hold i forget who gave this to me but
this was a screen cap from one of her
stories where she was looking at uh i
guess the
the trend at that time was looking at
your most popular podcasts and of course
you know her dad's number one and then
i'm right below which i'm kind of
flattered about
and hey even rich made the grade there
her her own podcast is only down at the
very bottom there and then of course
what she says is uh someone get me at
rational mail that's me
hi guys uh on my podcast please i know
i'm female but i
i don't bite i promise that
that one came back on me too and let me
i'll tell you why here in just a second
um but this is her on i would say i want
to say it was at least november 30th it
might have been
it might have been a little bit before
that but it was brought to my attention
on november 30th now how why do i know
that well because i would happen to be
in miami at the time
when this came up and somebody sent it
to me so i think somebody on the show
said have you seen this yet and i go oh
no i haven't so i went i looked at it oh
michaela wants to talk to me great
and i've instantly presumed it was
because of
this
i didn't think she wanted to talk to me
about my book she didn't know who i
actually know me from adam and clearly
she doesn't i mean she just more or less
has admitted this
to hafeez in the very beginning of his
show and then again at the beginning of
her of the our own interview here which
by the way was uh then i have to give
you the timeline here okay so we get it
she was unprepared all right can we
duh of course i got this
let's just say november 30th okay uh
this show
came out right about a week before that
so
that's that's the timeline right there
now
let's let's continue here so once i've
got this i'm going oh cool um let's
let's see if we can make this happen i
would not mind going on her show or
having her on my own and then i got the
i think it was she texted me
courtesy of myron um on december 2nd it
was like the very beginning i remember
she texted me while i was in miami and i
know it was right around the beginning
of that month
so i'm like okay cool we can do that i'm
in miami now i can't do it until i'm
done with i had to do uh you are here
and i had to do the
slightly offensive with elijah schaefer
and sydney watson so i'm like okay when
i get back from that
that engagement then we can we can do it
so that's what we did we set it up for
december 17th
and we recorded the show on december
17th now
her show the one that i just showed you
a minute ago and i'm going to continue
here in a second that did not drop until
december 29th right before new year's
which is exactly what she's saying this
is the last show of the year
so she between december 17th and
december 29th um she had all this time
to she could put she could have produced
it and dropped it anytime she wanted to
i don't know what her production
schedule is necessarily
but as she said you know she was very
upset and her dad was very upset about
the video that i had i put on you know
the kill to party video now
again not making comparisons to uh casey
anthony
in the thumbnail
she happens to think that of course she
takes it away thinking that
in my video that i am in some way saying
that she wants to kill her poor little
daughter that's not no that's not what
he's saying he's saying
he's saying
it's the same dynamic
she had a kid before she was ready it's
like that dynamic it probably would have
been better to have the kid with the
father the person you want to be with
i said but she will emphasize that and
ride that and lean into that for as long
as it will get her clicks for as long as
it's red meat for as long as she can you
know
say my name right
for as long as she can keep doing that
and that's why i feel like i have to do
this video sorry i know i was going to
let it go but she don't want to let it
go so here we are
uh let me let's continue so that's
that's uh i wanted to say that this
right here her uh saying that she had
just you know just nonchalantly wanted
to to talk to me prior to that is
[ __ ]
the video had already been out um the
people are more than likely uh
you know talking to her about how i was
this horrible mean guy
comparing her to casey anthony which by
the way casey anthony was one of
probably like four other examples i made
including herself in
the in that video i talked about
brittany renner i talked about um we
also talked about i talked about casey
anthony got to talk about her i talked
about um i forget who was i wanted to
say tommy learn but she doesn't have a
kid but i was making that again kill to
party is this it's like when women have
children in tow as a single mother that
is a very
heavy bag to be to be carrying around
especially if you're in the sexual
marketplace uh oh i was aisha curry
right that was another one that i uh
yeah
aisha curry
brought up she has kids with uh with
stephen curry and
still wants to be sexy still wants to
have an open marriage still one i talked
about her we didn't we didn't say oh you
compared me to
stephen curry you need to compare me to
brittany which i think honestly
comparing her to brittany renner
probably should have been more offensive
than really casey anthony
because of you know conditions here but
let's just you know that's where she
took it i'm sorry guys i was so hungry
i'm so sorry i i had to do it on stream
i didn't want to end the stream i'm
sorry but i in no way said oh you're
just like casey anthony you want to kill
your kid and put it in the trunk no but
that's the way you want to present this
and that's how you want to paint me
yeah as like he's the bad guy i don't
know that whole interview was so
emotional drove me crazy
and i get it like we're emotional people
but
just like logically the stuff they're
saying did not make sense i decided to
do the interview anyway because there
are a lot of rumors out there about my
life and it's actually really annoying
there's a fairly large group of people
that think i dragged dad to russia to
detox him somehow forced him on an all
meat diet somehow took over his brand
somehow party all the time hook up with
people etc none of those rumors are true
which will be clarified more in my book
but after watching rolo's video about
the entire thing
with my dad because he was in nashville
and i was setting up courses to be
filmed for him after hearing my dad's
rather loud thoughts on rolo i decided
i'd definitely like to talk to him
anyway clear away some of the mocks
surrounding my name hopefully i hope you
enjoy it and for any of you guys out
there that still think i'm some evil
human praying off of my dad and who
knows what else hopefully this
clarification helps even though it
probably wasn't needed which i'm also
aware of but enough is enough i wanted
to address these topics i didn't edit
this video other than removing about
four seconds of us talking about covid
and adding in clips
before we get into probably the weirdest
episode i've ever recorded this podcast
is sponsored by betterhelp all right
good enough i will pull that out there
now from that introduction by the way
which i had no idea she was saying that
that introduction happens sometime
between december 17th and december 29th
okay
so
once the interview is already done and
that's the interview and that's the
introduction she decided to put on wow
you're getting reaction videos making
about you
you're only flak when you're over target
someone made a reaction video or they
talk about the one eye
let's see
[Music]
what a feeling this day would come to be
honest
oh no i don't see one oh well
does that sound
like she's more concerned about being
compared to casey anthony or does that
sound more like she is a little bit more
concerned about having that picture
resurface
and in case you're wondering it's this
picture
and this picture
oh and this picture
whoa
[Music]
whoa
what
[Music]
what on earth
michaela
i'm sorry i was like
what
ma'am
i would be so embarrassed if my mom did
that
wait concerned about having that picture
resurface
and in case you're wondering it's this
picture
and this picture
oh and this picture
those are the things that she didn't
want anybody to have a look at because
of course her new good christian
boyfriend
whose name i'm not going to drop you can
go find
you can go look him up i you i'm sure
you probably already know um i'm i'm
fairly certain that she would very much
not like to have that picture
uh that picture and this picture
so it sounds more to me like it's more
about that than anything else
and the very fact that i had the
audacity to bring that up in some way is
is really the reason for this interview
it wasn't about some oh i wanted to talk
to him about his book because if it had
been
we would have talked about my book we
would have talked about anything else
but that's not what we did
i'm going to fast forward a little bit
more here because we have to just to put
things into perspective with the hafiz
interview we have to look at this
section right here so i'm going to put
i'm going to put her back in
and i have to scrub all the way up to i
think it was 40.
oh the donovan and pearl thing okay
[Music]
that's about it okay we'll go from here
them less marketable in the sexual
marketplace
that's what i was getting at but of
course everyone in the comments a little
bit primarily it's because that's when
men find women the most attractive right
during that sort of 18 to 28 era
however when women have a child such as
you at 23 years old it tends to put a
damper on finding a guy who's better
than say the guy that they ended up
divorcing or the guy that they ended up
marrying and then divorcing during that
time so that was the example that i was
using i i think what happens is this is
when i do something like that when i
when i use an example such as kcm i'm
not seeing and i even said this i don't
know how many times during that
four hour video i'm not saying that
that's what you wanted to do okay i'm
just using casey anthony as one prime
example of that i used other examples as
well brittany renner for example
locking down pj washington with the kid
when when the time was right for hershey
of course is 29 years old as well
so i was using her as an example but
people
hone in on something as extreme as say
like casey anthony i tried to present
the fact that that was the extreme
example of that
however the more general example of that
dynamic is that when women have become
single mothers particularly when they
become single mothers at an early age
it makes them less marketable in the
sexual marketplace that's what i was
getting at but of course everyone in the
comments yeah yeah that's a
like i understand what he's saying
perfectly
perfectly
that's he just compared you to casey
anthony well the thumbnail the thumbnail
this is my problem i just say all that
food cause i didn't eat all day today
it's like six o'clock so i just got
starving i just ate that food and i am
still so freaking hungry like i'm
starving right now but i gotta wait if i
wait like a half hour maybe i won't have
me and i do thank you for picking up a
good picture of me by the way but it
didn't have me and then kill to party
well let me explain to you the dynamics
of
did you see
that's what
he's talking about a dynamic not saying
like
again
do we see casey anthony anywhere in this
it's like it's like in one ear and out
the other respectfully i really like
michaela like genuinely i relate to her
in a lot of ways like having a very
like being very career driven and like
motivated to work and like having a dad
that
is very successful i relate to be honest
but
she doesn't come across as being too
sharp oh shut up respectfully shut up
she she's very clearly bright
like i don't know what her iq is but i'm
sure it's above average
do we
do we see a casey anthony on this
because i don't see her anywhere here
the other thing that i think is probably
upsetting her is the fact that she's
there with with andrew tate
thumbnail
creation which maybe do you think it
would have been better if she just said
yeah like i was partying
sorry
like whatever
now i'm done do you think that would
have been a better response you already
know but when you put people's face on
there when you put people's recognizable
faces on there when you have to see the
whites of their eyes and you're not the
first one i've ever done this with by
the way that's simply how you get
impressions on youtube right now i'm you
know i'll be all above board with that
because i'm not the first one to to
figure this out
and uh definitely
so so when you do something like that
then it gets then it draws like i've
said this before it's like i understand
that there's a salaciousness there's the
tmz effect right it's the it's uh you
want to give give your audience the red
meat however when i do so i'm trying to
give them steak with the sizzle so i'm
not doing it just to say oh look here
here's what she did right that's
that's not my point i say that in the
beginning of every single one of my
videos especially when i go after
somebody who i i think it would make a
good example of a particular like
illustration of a dynamic that i'm
talking yeah she was pulling the victim
card because that's what she keeps doing
she keeps saying
oh
he compared me to casey anthony instead
of debating the actual
like facts to be honest
i talked about uh emma was there emma
thorne i think is what her name was i
talked about her on a couple of
different occasions um and you know
people don't have a problem with that
because that's him with porn and then
you're met bella thorne by the way not
emma thorne kayla peterson so when i do
a thumbnail like of her nobody's saying
oh you she just compared he you know he
just compared youtube such and such it's
not an attack piece video i don't try to
do i don't do reaction videos i don't do
like take down videos or anything like
that if i think that somebody's right
because it's all he's talking about a
dynamic i i i feel like i keep repeating
myself because he keeps repeating
himself because
it's like he'll say he'll say okay this
is what i'm saying have you ever seen
that jordan peterson video where that
lady's like so you're saying this and
he's like no no no no
i'm saying this
i think that's what's like going on here
is rolo's like okay
this is what i'm saying and she's like
so you're saying
that i'm casey anthony and he's like i'm
not saying that you're casey anthony
i'm referring to a dynamic i've talked
about many other people it's not just
her
you're comparing me to a child's killer
no no no
i said multiple times
i'm not comparing you to her in that way
it's just the inconvenience of having
kids early
so you think i wish i didn't have my
daughter
bro
that serves as a good illustration for a
dynamic that i've written about in the
past or that i'm talking about currently
you know with whatever that i'm doing
then yes i'll do that because it's a
recognizable say oh okay now i get what
he's saying so it's it's more of like an
illustration rather than like oh i'm
gonna take you down in every single
video that i do this in i put out the
standard caveat this is not about the
individual this is about what's going on
so let's talk about what the dynamic is
not about it's not an attack but this is
youtube
this is twitter this is instagram this
is social media so everybody wants to
see like what we call a youtube blood
sport they want to see like oh did you
see that he compared you to this did you
see you compared to
how do i know that she knows this
already
because
around at the same time that she dropped
the video this particular video
she also had at least three different
clips
making it sound making it look as if i
was the one who was actually comparing
her to to casey anthony right she was
looking for that those red meat moments
not unlike by the way what dj academics
was doing with fresh and fit over the
flagrant two and we're not excuse me the
brittany renner
uh interview i don't
i don't think it's a bad thing to take
click bait for videos sorry i would do
it i would like of course you're gonna
take the clickbait where you look better
for your channel like duh i don't i
don't think that's
pearl would make a good wife but i could
never afford her extravagant lifestyle
do you think i have an extravagant
lifestyle sir
i'm the cheapest person i know
you know old all my clothes are like a
year old
and if they aren't a year old it's
because
somebody bought them for me to be honest
people know this [ __ ]
this is not anything that is is
revolutionary i do spend money on food
though
that's pretty extravagant i do get food
delivered it's it's a poor habit tory to
anyone in fact i think i'm being fairly
measured in all of this
i'm saying look she does exactly the
same thing
i mean does that shot right there on the
cover of whatever magazine it is like
why not just do something where she's
just like you know very studious and
looks more professorial like her dad
right why not do something like that
well of course you're not good
of course do that please go on the
magazine and look like that but that's
there's a reason that that works and the
other one doesn't
that's why
that's not me like like trying to be you
know cagey or or
duplicitous about anything she does
exactly the same thing she was very
upset about this
thumbnail
when i in fact pulled it from i'm not on
vacation i moved this thumbnail on her
own damn sight
so to tell me that oh you're
you're you're about making me casting me
in a bad light you're in you're right i
am still going and guys put a donation
in the chat poor favor you already know
i am trying
to do a podcast called the pre-game why
why the pre-game is better than the
party because you have better
conversations it's less people and it's
fun
and i want to get four more mics and
another sound board
unfortunately my sound board has been
delayed in the mail like it's like two
days late i'm gonna kill somebody but
i'm gonna order another
anyways
um
and you dropped 500 on a new sound toy i
dropped it on with donations though like
i used people's donations for the
soundboard
indirectly uh comparing me to casey
anthony well not in this shot
and certainly not in this shot
that you used yourself
so
what's the problem here the only thing i
can think of is that you are lying
you're full of [ __ ]
and you're upset because of
i should you're upset because of this
shot right here
and you're upset about me talking about
that bringing that back up at a very
inopportune time for you
i'm sorry i didn't know it was going to
be a bad time for you
if you want to hit me up maybe i would
have like you know measured it down a
little bit but i didn't know
how am i supposed to know that
but even still
this is you know i i've done several
episodes
on
how
women have digital footprints today
and
michaela you have a huge [ __ ] digital
footprint my dear
huge this is this right here is that's
part of your digital footprint pregame
sounds like fresh and fit lists less
thoughts and extremism it's probably
similar yeah it's similar to their setup
um
yeah similar
less extreme less thoughts
damn near everything and it won't be as
rad pill like it'll be a little more pop
culture like i'm i wouldn't consider
myself full on red pill but i do
understand the concepts very well shot
of you and scarlett looks like she's an
accessory
he bought her at claire's
and she uh set the set the stuffed
animal on the bed and i'll take a
picture of myself for my
to to promote my brand of me
and again it's like i'm
i started off this video
with ellie
ellie no
no
jordan peterson
talking about how we need to have more
coherent families
we need to have more structured families
you know the
and you know he did pretty well in that
interview i'd have to say because that's
from like 2018 i believe but that was
just recently dropped as a short on his
channel so somebody thought it was
pertinent right about now and it's like
do you not see the irony
in all that maybe he didn't do it maybe
he didn't put that that particular short
up personally but somebody who controls
his brand sure as hell did
and i can go and i and i'm very
i i don't want to get too
wrapped up in this i don't want to get
too like because there's so many videos
that i could go and pull from 2017 all
the way up to about 2019
where i mean one after the other of dr
jordan peterson talking about how
important it is for women to be home
with the kid
for how important it is
for careerist women to reconsider to
rethink their lives
[Music]
he has the man has spitting facts
but i love jordan peterson but he's me
he's making points i understand though
but he like
where she's coming from because again my
dad's very successful my dad's very like
driven and it's tough to not like have
that passed down to me
like i work very hard at what i do like
i stream for hours i spend hours editing
videos that i put out like
i understand like that
some somewhat to be honest the like want
to be ambitious and like work a lot
um however
i don't know yeah it looks pretty
contradictory doesn't it
because they need to be home with the
kid and there's nothing wrong with being
home and he makes the case you know like
feminists say that it's you know you
need to be out there you know conquering
the world ladies and gentle female and
and he was just very
concerned trolling but very concerned at
the fact that you know today's women
careerist women
are eschewing
rescuing
motherhood and then well then what later
on they're going to go well i'd never
had a kid blah blah blah blah well what
if you did have a kid and
the guy you were with is
you know you divorced him out of hand
and now you're moving on to
what moving on to bigger and better
things and becoming exactly that careers
woman that your dad warned about
in 2017 and 2018
2019
and it's resurfacing by the way those
videos resurfacing in 2022.
so i mean
that's true look at
my me and my siblings are all so
different like some people are just born
a certain way like more masculine more
feminine
um and that's the thing that people
don't really
like you can only do so much even if
it's your own kids some kids are just
stubborn excuse me
for seeing the inconsistencies here
but i'm seeing inconsistencies here
now i want to keep going with this
because she she's going to drop some
other little gems in in the hafiz thing
here so let's keep going
i talked about this uh recently on um on
elijah schaefer's show as well so um
it's it's there's this
um i think there's this need for people
to have sort of this get to get a rise
out of you i was on i was on you are
here with elijah shaffer and um sydney
watson and uh ariel i forget her last
name scarcella or scarella she's the you
know lesbian
uh you know uh traditional conservative
i guess now
and
when i was on there and we were having
our back and forth
everyone in the chat wanted us to like
be at each other's throats right because
they're looking for that it's bread and
circuses
so when i put something out like that or
if there's some kind of comparison to
you to like say casey anthony that's not
my intent to do that but that's what the
audience wants to see
you see what i'm saying so maybe you're
getting the wrong impressions you're
like i'm not trying to make you look
like casey anthony i just mentioned you
in the same show as
casey anthony
okay i guess i just don't usually play
into that
like on my channel i get the clickbaity
stuff but if i'm like doing it probably
no i really don't as you're doing it
though no i really don't i definitely
have not made an indirect comparison
between someone and someone who murdered
her child and put her in a trunk that's
what she wanted to say throughout the
entire that was that was her
money shot right there she was waiting
to deliver that line
and the reason why i know that
is because it's entirely out of context
of what we were talking about right
there
when i was saying you
and and michaela you do engage in
exactly the same kind of youtube
marketing the same kind of blood sports
the same kind because you would not be
talking about me
on hafiz's show if that weren't [ __ ]
true
right there black and white you're doing
it right there i'm sure i'm i'm about
100 sure that i'm
rolling always makes points i don't care
what anyone says
it's annoying
why do you roll up why did you have to
ruin the petersons like of all the
people the petersons i love the
petersons
and like
somehow
these videos just don't they don't hit
the same ever since you did this whole
hit piece on his daughter
they just they just don't i still love
him i still love jordan but
it's like you get too close to the sun
you get burnt
later on down the road i'm you're
probably gonna you know
say my name right
so don't get uh again she wanted to drop
that that was where she wanted to place
them the money shot in all of that
thinking that she's going to shame me or
say oh you uh you did this indirectly no
i didn't i just said that that was not
my intent
and i said that everyone on youtube
engages in that same kind of let's go to
game the algorithm
that's why you use shots like this
that's why you use
that's why you use shots like this
that's why this gets clicks michaela
now i'm not engaging in that that kind
of
bread and circus is [ __ ]
[ __ ]
look at the look at the people that you
bring on look at the look at the topics
that you're talking about whether it's
about you know
the the the current state of the beer
bug or whatever i didn't want to say the
word right
or
look at the look at the people that
you're talking to look at the and i'm
sure that they're very intelligent
people and you're having a good
conversation
but there's still that element of
marketing there's still that element of
how do i get more people to get eyes on
how do i grow my channel everyone wants
to grow their goddamn channel
bro
do i need to start taking off my clothes
to get this to get this [ __ ] running
i'm getting poorer
yo if you've called into my show a
couple times if you've watched more than
like two three of my live streams if
you've watched two or three of my videos
and you don't subscribe one we have beef
two
consider sending a donation okay
if you're out here watching a ton of my
content and i'm entertaining you
i work very hard to do this and i really
i want to get the best
content i possibly can for you and i
promise you this live show is going to
be so lit it's going to be so lit
so consider even if it's just two
dollars like consider sending a donation
okay
and i have i think above all of anyone
in the manosphere right now
i'm the one who is more concerned
with steak more than sizzle remember the
uh comparison i made with ryan stone
we're talking about uh
uh the nachos the nachos analogy
you know i want good nachos i don't want
just like chips and cheese i put a lot
of good stuff into my nachos right
and they're still nachos
they're still chips they're still cheese
but there's a lot more to it than just
the than just the you know schlep on you
know drowning drown the chips and cheese
so let me keep going here because
after the money shot there's some
actually some pretty good stuff here
that was not my intent anyways okay well
i'm really glad to hear that that makes
me feel better and then let's see what
else do i have then we can get to your
book okay finding god as convenient like
that
irritated me
i don't know why but the way she went
about that just like irritated me
my problem isn't the actual sincerity of
the belief i mean they can say whatever
they want we can decide to believe it or
not okay well let's uh that's sorry my
bad i want to pull that out all right
let me pull her up now this was where i
wanted to go like that type of content
and i was like well
people like like i don't just because
people like to to watch that kind of
thing doesn't mean that you should be
devoting your life to making that kind
of content like what kind of life is
that yeah no well let's see the the
content that i've devoted my life
devoted
the content that i have been doing for
the last 20 years has been consistent
for 20 [ __ ] years i've never changed
my my my path i've always had an
obligation to objective truth i've
always stated what i've done i've never
taken any of my books off of you know
offline
i've never taken any videos offline i've
never pulled a box i shouldn't say that
i did pull the kia saw the original
kiyosaki video recently but i did that
at request and then i put it back up
later on
just was the wrong time but it's still
up
my i have never pivoted to the god pill
i've never pivoted to mgtow i've never
pivoted to to any other
movement or whatever else you want i
have always been consistent in my
message
so don't give me that crap about you
know oh well you know that bread and
circus stuff doesn't seem like it's very
genuine get the [ __ ] out of here i've
been do when i was started this you were
in
but grammar school
grammar school yeah probably what what
were you like seventh grade eighth grade
i've been i would argue arguably i've
been doing what i've been doing 20 20
some odd years for at least as long as
your dad has been doing his thing
and that's the thing i was i try to
explain guys as a person
who
you know obviously i don't affiliate
myself with the red pill manage for any
of the other stuff as a person who has a
lot of friends in the no but you're
happy to talk about it constantly hafiz
and they tell me everything like if
anyone's in the space who makes a
significant amount of money i know
okay
did you just not i mean i'm confused
here hafiz now let's talk about you for
a second here i'm confused because
about four or five minutes prior to this
you were saying i read all the stuff i'm
on top of all this stuff i i understand
the research i'm i'm on top of it yeah
that's very true pick a side roommates
because i think okay this is what i
think the roommates or huffys feels like
i think he feels like the red pill is
just like a little too negative for his
brand and it's very like because a lot
of the red pill brands are like fresh
and fit
it's most of them talking about good
stories are negative it's like mostly
negative and i know they have their
self-improvement stuff but what are they
known for
it's not it's not
but the roommates are more known i think
for their self-improvement than
the true nature of women but
i think he probably still holds some red
pill beliefs and some what do they call
blue pill i don't know this and then yet
not right now you're saying you're not
in the manosphere and you have to get it
third party from other guys
what the [ __ ] is it is it one or the
other is are you on top of your game you
understand all this stuff and you're
like a somewhat semi-authority on it or
you just don't care enough you're not
really in the ministry and you have to
hear a third party what what is it
personally
and interesting and
we talk about everything
and one thing is clear as day is that
they
i remember watching a video with logan
paul and logan paul made a point where
he's saying there's difference between
making good content and making good
youtube content
because you can make a good video
but if it's not you know effects well
and thumbnail well entitled well yeah it
won't do well on youtube doesn't mean
it's not a good video this means that
to do good on youtube you know you must
know how to hack youtube and hack the
audience's mind via youtube and so
a lot of the people they realize i can
either
do
youtube hacky videos
and make fifty thousand a month
or i can do
more positive good content and make 10.
when you're young
or when you're just trying to just but
this is what annoys me to start talking
about rolos
huh
rolo isn't
he's not really in it for the money to
be honest he doesn't really do the click
bait too much i mean a little bit
but how much can you clickbait a
three-hour freaking stream like he's
talking about fresh and fit that is like
what he's talking about
when you're really just making content
for money
why would you why would you sacrifice
forty thousand dollars you know so a lot
of people in the space is like
they know there's just fun fact i
purchased a one-on-one i've purchased
i'm gonna do a video review reviewing
the one-on-ones
that
that i that i've purchased because i
think it'd be good for you guys to know
which ones i felt like were helpful and
which ones weren't
and
surprisingly haphiz was like the least
helpful out of all of them
like
like if i had to rate his i would put
his on the bottom and i love his content
so i was so disappointed
because
one this man was driving i paid like 150
for 30 minutes of his time i'm like
you can't even you can't even take the
time to not be on the road
and
this is what annoys me is i'll ask this
happened with another creator too but
i'm not i'll ask them i'm not gonna
it might be it's probably my fault
because i'm not the best at phrasing
what i want to say the best so maybe i
didn't ask the question in the right way
but what i was trying to ask is what is
the best way to like build a business on
youtube okay and like monetize content
and he spent like 10 minutes like 20
minutes lecturing me about how it's not
about the money
you can't just do it for money i'm like
i know i can't just do it for money
but i gotta make money at some point
um yeah so i was
i was extremely disappointed in that one
i was like 150 bucks i was down the
drain
down the fricking drain oh my gosh
um
yeah i wouldn't that would not be my
first choice if i'd recommend like
classes to take or like
coaching based on that you know i'm
could have just been a bad day i don't
know but
beef i got beef
this this three four five extra money i
can i can tell it to you for a fact i
know if i wanted to make money
there's a certain kind of video i know
for a fact if i do it
it's going to make the lead attorney is
the steve harvey of manosphere
i just uh money but oh well would that
be with that certain kind of video be
getting women into your live studio
situation there and talking to them
not unlike fresh and fit in the after
hours show would that would it be kind
of like that
because that's what you've been doing
lately on the roommates just pointing
that out atheist now
rolo come on you know the way he talks
to the girls is not the same way that
fresh and fit do
it might be
more like the black manosphere's version
of the view
but that's the template
okay
so maybe is that is that what we're
going for
you'll notice that i i would challenge
you
to find any time at any time of my
videos
where i'm pitching
i mean i'll throw my book out there but
i don't put like a uh if you look at the
very beginning of this video i don't put
some long for maybe i should but you
know some four or nine
you know 40 second you know one minute
video
promoting my
you know manhood course
or i don't even i don't even real and
maybe i should maybe i'm wrong about
this maybe maybe you maybe you're the
genius here but i don't advertise my
book without and you know i mention it
in passing but i don't put ads for my
book in any of my videos i don't put ads
for my [ __ ] i don't even put ads in my i
will go and do affiliate marketing for
john from modern life dating from aaron
clary from troy to troy francis to
sterling cooper but you know what you
will not see you will not see any of
that crap from me
because this is where i come when we
talk about ideas
so yeah i you i think you're 100 right
there are definitely a formulaic
template of videos that are going to do
well
very easy to see and it's all about
impressions and if in case you don't
know what impressions are whenever you
are most people don't search for videos
what they do is they go to youtube and
primarily on their phone most people if
you look at the pie chart
demographically speaking most people
watch
youtube on their phones there is a
specific marketing algorithm
for getting impressions and what
impressions are is nobody searches for
videos they look at what's suggested to
them they say this is more helpful than
what hafiz
told me
and that 30 minute
30 minute 150 dollar session of these
like oh my god he was just like
oh he would go on and on you can't you
can't do it for the money you can't do
it for the money i know oh my god sorry
oh my god that made me so mad that made
me so bad i like i did that call
of course like i didn't say that on the
call because i was like
um okay but
i swear to god that right there was more
information then i got out of that 30
minute session
because he just like accused me of doing
it for the wrong reasons the whole time
i'm like look
i'm just trying to like
figure out the best because at that time
i was doing rap reactions
and all my [ __ ] kept getting demonetized
but i was getting like i got 10 000
subscribers in a month
but i had to stop doing them because i
kept getting demonetized and nobody
could freaking help me like nobody could
give me the answer i was looking for
um
which is fine you know i just pivoted
and like did something else
but like i can't be doing this [ __ ] for
free anyways i was oh my god i'm still
bad i want my 150 dollars back
i want it back
by youtube and they go oh there's a new
one from rollo oh there's a new one from
the roommates there's a new one from
michaela and then they click on that
they didn't go michaela peterson they no
they're not searching
nine times out of ten i mean it's like
maybe so i mean if you're looking for
very specific content maybe you are but
most people just take whatever's like
sort of fed to them oh that's a funny
comment
i i never said i was doing it for the
money i just need money too
yeah like okay do you guys know i get
paid below minimum wage on this if it
was about the money i would have left
and got a real job i swear to god i
would have because you guys don't even
know how much time i spent behind the
scenes like
trying i i don't work
i work hard i don't work smart that's my
problem
but
but
but like you can't you have to make some
sort of money to survive
uh maybe if you didn't blow money on
those sessions you wouldn't have to ask
for a million dollar super chats i was
hoping
to get an roi
i was hoping oh my god oh no what did i
do
sorry i got way too into this
i was hoping to get an roi like when he
answered and he was driving i was like
really
for real
bro i'm gonna like look it i just did a
one-on-one session with someone the
other day
i'm much cheaper than everyone else okay
75 bucks
for 45 minutes that's decent deal right
or not you know you
no need to comment people were asking me
in the comments to set it up so i was
like what the hell
i'll offer it see if anyone wants it and
there is a question he asked me and i
didn't know the answer so i was like you
know what i'm going to talk to a couple
people i'll get back to you
why because i'm like this man paid for
my time and i didn't know an answer to a
question i'm not gonna rant and tell him
he's only doing it for the money
oh my gosh sorry i'm done i'm done what
does anyone know what time stamp i was
at
um i've had wheat waffles on before i
would put him on again kind of like even
though
he was a little bit
he had some rude comments about me later
but whatever i don't care um
is are you on top of your game you
understand all this stuff does anyone
know what i hear you're like a somewhat
semi authority on it or you just don't
care enough
i like don't even know
prefez was trying to protect his
investments he don't need you out here
taking his fan base okay number one
i was doing rap video reactions then i
was barely i'd only done like
one or two kevin samuels like the
majority of my videos was rap
music
oh my god
sorry i'm just
134 okay
i'm just i just want my money back i
just want my money back he saw you as a
threat he did it i
i can promise you this man did not
see me as a threat at all
he
i promise you like
he just wanted to like lecture me about
his ideology and his beliefs
about doing [ __ ] for the right reason
75 i know a guy across i knew someone
was going to put
put this in the comments complaining
about the price look look this is what i
did
this is what i did i said
someone in the comments says do you do
one-on-one and they said you should
charge between this price and this price
and 75 bucks was in the middle i said
what the hell
i'll put it on there
i'm not
it was to raise money for a sound board
who am i if he wants to pay me for it
so i've only done like a couple like
i've barely done any but i'm like
i just
i would never
uh you can quote me on this i will never
take a one-on-one session driving i
think that is so rude that is so rude
oh my gosh i'm done i'm sorry i'm done
most people if you look at the pie chart
demographically speaking most people
watch
youtube on their phones there is a
specific marketing algorithm
for getting impressions and what
impressions are is nobody searches for
videos they look at what's suggested to
them by youtube and they go oh there's a
new one from rollo oh there's a new one
from the roommates there's a new one
from michaela and then they click on
that they didn't go michaela peterson
they no they're not searching
nine times out of ten i mean it's like
maybe some i mean if you're looking for
very specific content maybe you are but
most people just take whatever's like
sort of fed to them
from youtube
okay great that's an impression
now when you click on that that's called
click through rate
and a click-through rate of about five
or six percent from the impressions that
you're getting which are measured in
numbers those are the statistics that
you really need to look into those are
the ones that actually have something to
do with the growth of your [ __ ]
channel hafiz probably said pretty white
chicks talking to black men not on my
watch no it wasn't guys it was not like
that he couldn't even see me it was a
phone call
i just
oh my god that made me so bad
oh my god
so when i see when somebody shows me and
says oh man
fresh and fit lost 38 000 subs in the
month of august uh because of all that
that horrible debit call
debacled let me say it right so you guys
don't throw rocks at me
that horrible situation
you know it's actually been more helpful
than anyone i paid for donovan if you
guys ever need to pay for a session you
should pay for donovan because he has
actually been so helpful with this
youtube [ __ ] i don't know i don't ask
him for like dating advice or anything
but like with youtube [ __ ] oh my god
donovan is so helpful he's a great
mentor actually and preach right they
lost they lost so many subs
they're like
okay you know how much money they made
off of super chats in the month of
august they were the number one super
chatted show certainly in the united
states and i think they were like number
three
in worldwide they made a hundred
thousand dollars in just
gross in in super chats during the month
do you think they give one rat's ass
about losing those subs no and where are
they now
well i think they're on their way to 570
000 subs right now i'm not saying subs
are
you know at least a point of pride for
sure
they do mean something but you can take
a small channel and make a [ __ ] ton of
money on a small channel because it's
not about subs it's about engagement
it's about what let me tell you i could
tell you that from my tick tock
i made more money when i had way less
followers i got a bunch of followers
from my last relationship and when
we like stopped posting together for a
while because it just became a lot on
the relationship but i had all these
followers but like once
i stopped like they were all wanting to
see relationship content when i couldn't
give them that like it became way less
and it was
anyways it just was bad the impression
of the video if i go and i'm a new
channel and i've got 20 000 subs and i
get a scoop on
uh you know interviewing ivanka trump or
whatever if i go and i find a
celebrity and i get some dirt or
whatever like that
that engagement is gold that virality
doesn't matter what your subs are it
doesn't matter what comments are just
meant with the sorry please give me
comments and likes and everything else
of course there's a little bit of you
know
push and pull from that but it's all
right michaela's going on fresh and fit
today
oh that'll be fun really about
impressions and click-through rate and
then audience retention of course too
those are very important factors
they know this he knows this
obviously clearly
she knows stuff like this now granted
this is on her her instagram but even on
instagram and social media the same
things apply
and what is that well you gotta have a
face you gotta you have a recognizable
face i tried to make this case
in the video where i'm explaining to her
how this stuff works she knows how this
works the reason she dodged and ducked
that is because she didn't want to talk
about that she just wanted to deliver
the money shot which is oh you compare
me to casey anthony
if you want that live show i know i have
to keep asking but i'm going to i don't
care no shame if you guys have been
enjoying this stream okay and you've
watched three or more of my streams okay
please consider donating to the channel
all donations are going towards the live
show that i'm starting hopefully in like
two weeks and my goal is to get a
thousand dollars worth of equipment it'd
include four mics and a sound board
um right now we're at like 175 we also
raised a thousand dollars last week
and that bought the first four mics in
the first sound board but i'm hoping to
get two
so
if you would like to see that show
consider donating thank you
woman who killed her kid and put her in
the trunk by the way not convicted of
that
most likely she did but not convicted of
that
still don't know who the killer is
that video will perpetuate the
negativity that a lot of guys feel okay
uh one last thing here
negativity whatever you know i'm not
gonna say that you shouldn't like
watch what goes into your brain like
what's who is influencing you i've
you've heard me say this before i hate
the word influencer i hate the title of
influencer
i love it you have no idea
oh my gosh you have no idea how um
how much social media like shapes us my
dad does have never had social media and
like he is so much less stressed he's
so much more stress-free like
he always tells me comparison is the
thief of joy and it really is because
even even when we're talking about red
pill topics what is it doing we're
always comparing ourselves to each other
whether it's like women with our younger
selves
um men with like money what percent am i
in this this this and this like
when you compare yourselves to others
constantly that is the thief of joy and
it's too bad this stuff is kind of like
fun to watch because
uh thank you so much dan for the super
chat
i appreciate it guys even if it's just
two dollars like i appreciate it so much
um
i should stream in a bikini
i am not confident enough to take off my
clothes on this camera no thank you
instagram influencer i'm a youtube
influence i'm a youtuber right i'm an
influencer okay great what are you
influencing that's that sounds i'm sorry
but maybe it's just me being gen x or
whatever that scares the [ __ ] out of me
influencer okay well you know who else
is an influencer um let's see cult kim
kardashian leaders uh televangelists kim
kardashian politicians kim kardashian um
name name the person you know
name the person who has influenced you
the most you're like
okay was it a good influence was a bad
influence
right artist seduction people gave
robert greene so much crap about artist
seduction but seduction's not just about
like seducing you know your lovers it's
also about seduction and influencing
others what is that a was it napoleon
hill how do you know when friends and
influence others
so yeah and so and what influence what
is the easiest way to influence what do
people want
give them what they want
the reason why freshman fit is so
popular in the after hour show
is because that's the demand
there that's not like they created it's
not their marketeering that that market
already existed they just happened to be
the first ones to tap it now everybody's
going oh wait
we need an ethical
refreshing fit
get the [ __ ] out of here
damn that's kind of i feel called out
i'm still going to try to do this show
though you wanna know why maury povich
is popular that's why they want bread
and circuses i tried to make that point
in the interview with michaela peterson
you're never gonna that's not gonna be a
clip that she drops right with on
december 29th with the rest of the
the video
was like when i said
you know dj academics was doing
fresh and fit dirty by dropping that one
quick hit vid and even
just recently dj academics has pretty
much copped to exactly that he says of
course i'm going to give them what they
want of course i'm going to put that
that one clip out there of course i'm
going to do that because that's what
goes viral man
okay
well it's going viral and you're still
kind of doing your friends dirty
at the same time it's the same principle
but i'm a bad bad man because you know
why this this is the image that i led
with
so i'm a very bad person
yeah well when it when it pisses you off
when somebody calls you out on that yeah
then you're a bad person but hafiz
he knows this because he's trying to
emulate that same kind of success on his
own show right now but it's going to be
the kinder gentler version of
a fresh and fit and subsequently it's
going to fail
because that's not what sells that's not
that there's no demand for that there's
demand for that on the view huffies go
on the view you know i hear whoopi
goldberg is going to get like canned by
abc or disney or whatever maybe you can
be the next you know whoopi goldberg on
the view
that's probably where you should go now
you know maybe that's a good career
choice you should maybe i should get a
finder's fee for the view
you can replace whoopi because that's
essentially what you are
right now you're whoopi goldberg you're
the you're the male version of whoopi
goldberg
and when you're talking about how oh
it's this negative influence and
everything well yeah it can be for sure
and people give fresh and fit grief for
it all the time
and they give me the grief for it all
the time i even called it out i've done
several videos on what i call red meat
you don't even know what the term red
meat was if it wasn't for me or maybe i
don't know
okay i think i got i've been streaming
for so long i think i understand
um
oh my gosh
i
a hundred
percent did i really i was kind of
surprised at how emotional michaela was
i mean we should we're still women we
can't
undo our biological hardwiring but i was
surprised i did not
take
that interview as like she won like i
thought she lost actually when i watched
the full interview with rolo
and i also thought that the conversation
with hafiz was like very disrespectful
not disrespectful like sorry i'm getting
tired
very um
like i just i didn't really think they
they said nothing like practically the
whole time they just literally said
nothing
you want to see 10 push-ups
um what are you gonna super chat me for
free no
i was actually debating going to the gym
but i have a game in the morning so i'm
like
[Music]
okay guys
i'm gonna go i appreciate everyone going
doing this today um if anyone wants to
donate for the show my
paypal is just pearly things and my pa
or no no my
my cash app is just pearly